the way you handled yourself today was
quite admirable though I fear your earth
faces a far more pressing threat than
anything posed by our Confederacy is
this the attack well this warrant might
be coming it shall be the end of your
planet that's why Hale had a deal with
the Confederacy to fight beside us a
confederacy never intended to honor this
agreement nor could it even if it so
desired it was merely a deception to
extort the resources from your planet
before time ran out which now it has
what are you saying
Thanos and his forces have begun an
assault on your world even as we speak
well then I've got to get down there
with the Avengers and take on this
Thanos Thanos his strength is unrivaled
you will lose even with your powerful
friends fighting alongside you
no perhaps there might still be away
seems the situation is worse than we
feared the earth is under attack by an
alien named Thanos what about the
Confederacy - they agree to help us or
bark and bite I'm afraid we're on our
own general we have to get back and do
what exactly the only option left make
me invincible excuse me I struck up a
conversation with this guy from the
Confederacy he tells me there's untapped
deposits of gravitonium under the
earth's surface and you want to get it
out and power yourself up more well that
way I can handle any threat the earth
faces I can be the shield hey everybody
it's Charlie I got a bunch of requests
to do a video for this agents of shield
infinity war crossover they directly
call out Thanos in the war that he's
bringing to earth so I'll explain what
the timeline is in how what they're
doing on shield has to do with infinity
war so if you're finding me for the
first time this is just the beginning of
all the Marvel stuff that's gonna be
happening be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos there's gonna be a whole
bunch of Avengers force stuff happening
really soon - especially Captain Marvel
there's a new round of that Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway that I'll explain at
the end of the video - so what you have
going on here is you have Glenn Talbot
who has become the graviton character
from the comics he's even wearing the
comic book costume they remember they
introduced the character during season 1
of shield relatively early in the run I
think it was episode 4 or 5 or something
like that he basically got dipped in a
vat of gravitonium turned into
gravitonium so there was like this
entity that was alive within it the TV
show has incorporated some elements of
Hydra as well as a space Confederacy
involving a bunch of different races
that are kind of like vultures picking
over Thanos as leavings so in this big
time-travel plot Glenn Talbot eventually
infuses himself using a Captain America
style birth chamber like remember the
chamber that they used to infuse Captain
America with the Super Soldier Serum
Hydra made another version of that they
found a way to bind elements to people
so they found gravitonium Glenn Talbot
had been brainwashed by Hydra so he'd
been crazy already came up with a
brilliant idea that he would save
everyone by fusing himself with
gravitonium but it only made him more
crazy now he has gravitons powers from
comics he's wearing his comic book
costume he's got like full mustache
twirling comic book villain so bring you
back around to Thanos this space
Confederacy made a deal with general
Hale from Hydra
to protect the earth in exchange for
concessions after it was over she was
going to give them access to precious
resources they could only get from Earth
like a glorified mining operation but
come to find out in this last episode
that the Confederacy never intended to
protect Earth from Thanos I'll talk
about that in a minute there's some
fundamental flaws with the thesis that
shield puts forth about what Thanos is
gonna do on earth because we just saw it
go down during infinity war but the
whole idea is is that everyone's
terrified of Thanos so the Confederacy
uses Earth's fear of this to drive a
deal with Hydra that they don't intend
on holding up they're gonna turn earth
into a glorified mining operation in the
future anyway which is what they tease
at the beginning of agents of shield
this season so all season long the whole
deal has been earth being blown up
cracked apart in the future and they
think that Daisy Johnson did it but come
to find out that it's actually probably
going to be graviton aka general Talbot
here that does it
trying to find more gravitonium in
Earth's core so you're asking where this
falls in the timeline relative to
infinity war because they're still
talking about protecting Earth from the
coming conflict that means that Thanos
has not come to earth yet and because we
need to talk about the plot of infinity
war I'll say careful for spoilers for
infinity war if you have not seen the
movie yet so during that movie first the
black order is sent to earth to try and
get the time stone in the mine stone
they fail by the end of the movie Thanos
sends a portion of his fleet to earth
with the outriders to invade Wakanda to
take the mine stone because Doctor
Strange gives him the time stone when
they're on Titan then Thanos comes to
earth to take the mine stone himself at
the very end of the movie so all of that
happens after what's happening on agents
of shield right now so we can assume now
that everything that's happened on
agents of shield this season has been in
the 6-1-6 universe there was a big
theory that there might be some
alternate dimension stuff going on as a
way to explain how they weren't around
for infinity war but then directly
addressing Thanos
quest for the Infinity stones just means
that it's happening in the same reality
they did say that there would be more
crossovers happening I don't know what
that's going to entail because this is
all still happening before the offense
of infinity war I think what will happen
is is it the finale will happen before
infinity war starts there are only two
more episodes episode 21 in episode 22
Talbot even said during that clip that
he wants to rush down to the earth to
help join the Avengers against Thanos
one of the fundamental flaws and the
idea that they're putting forth here
though is that the Thanos intends to
destroy the earth and that's not at all
what he's trying to do during infinity
war you learned that his plan is to turn
the universe into a paradise by erasing
half of all life like he talks to Gamora
do you know what's happened to your
planet since I've visited it it's a
paradise now the people want for nothing
so at no point during this season of
agents of shield did Thanos ever intend
to destroy the earth so I think you
could chalk that inconsistency up to two
minor things you can kind of explain it
with a little back bending on a story
level like oh maybe the aliens were just
lying about fan o's but also i think
it's part of the problem with the
showrunners on agents of shield not
knowing what the full plot of infinity
war is like the directors of infinity
war said that Mark Ruffalo doesn't even
get completed scripts so if they don't
give completed scripts to Mark Ruffalo
then they're not going to be giving
scripts to a bunch of other show runners
that aren't working on infinity war
themselves so I think it wanting to
incorporate elements of Thanos and
infinity war they hyped it up just a
little bit more than what was actually
going to happen
the only real large-scale invasion that
happens is during Wakanda like you can't
even call the one in New York with
Squidward and Cole obsidian and invasion
it's really just them visiting to take
down Doctor Strange and even at the end
of the movie the damage is largely
localized to the outer rim of Wakanda
they don't even destroy most of the city
of Wakanda because that one ship that
tries to land right on top of the shield
blows up in the shield holds it's meant
to show you how tough Lokhande is we're
it not for the finger-snap they totally
would have destroyed that army
especially after Thor showed up but if
you guys didn't know Phil Coulson is
actually in the Captain Marvel movie
because that's set during the 90
so Phil Coulson hasn't died yet during
the Avengers meaning he's totally fair
game to run around the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but we don't know exactly what
he's gonna be doing during that he'll be
a member of shield probably but that's
all we know so I will say that if shield
gets renewed next year remember Captain
Marvel's being released early next year
before Avengers for that agent to shield
if it does get that season 6 will try to
incorporate Captain Marvel stuff in a
bigger way but as of right now they have
not renewed the show I don't know how
long they're gonna wait before they
announce something like that I think
they're gonna wait to see what the
ratings are for the entire season after
the finale there are a number of
different factors that go into
cancellation renewal so whatever ends up
happening after the finale we'll talk
about season six stuff but I wouldn't
worry about that too much right now so
what'll happen is is I have new infinity
war Thor to post later tonight that
should be up in the next couple of hours
but leave all your Marvel requests in
the comments below since I wasn't
expecting this crossover moment I'll
just leave the giveaway for the Infinity
Gauntlet open till I post that Thor
video so I'll name the winner when I
post that later tonight so look out for
that while you wait for everything click
here for my Avengers 4 title video and
click here for my new Deadpool trailer
and alert about some of the Bands stuff
that they already had to take out of the
movie thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]